And we pick up from where we left off the last day.
Louisa says one day we were in this contrast and the pain was so great that I couldn't
stop crying.
Now in Volume 1, Louisa is a teenager, so the crying is okay.
When she gets to Volume 20, it wouldn't be toleration, you have to grow.
So my good Jesus told me I want to content you in everything that's because she's giving
herself completely to him.
I feel so drawn towards you.
That's because she is opening herself up completely to him, that I cannot do without
doing what you want.
Now notice it's the Lord who is telling Louisa that he wants to do what she wants and it
has got to be the other way around completely, hasn't it?
If up until now I have removed the external life from you, that is she was taken away
from all normal social contacts and I've manifested myself to you, now I want to draw
your soul to me.
So it's one thing to take away everything that hinders on the outside, it's quite another
matter internally to go to the Lord because you know that it's not the habit that makes
the monk and it's not the building that makes the monk.
It's what happens inside in the monk's heart that makes the monk.
So that's what he's saying here, now that we've got rid of all the external distractions,
let's deal with all the internal stuff.
I want to draw your soul to me so that wherever I go, you may come along because in the divine
will, wherever the divine will is, we go there.
That's everywhere.
In this way, you will be able to enjoy me more and bind yourself to me more intimately
than you have done in the past.
One morning I don't remember well but I think about three months had passed of my continuously
staying in bed and as I was in my usual state, her usual state as you know is an ecstatic
state, my sweet Jesus came with the look all lovable as a young man of about 18 years of
age.
Now very seldom does she see Jesus at that age.
She either sees him as a child or at the time when he did his public ministry or how beautifully
he was with his golden hair all curly.
He seemed to chain my thoughts, my affections and my heart, that's your Deuteronomy 6.4.
You shall love the Lord your God with all your heart.
From his forehead, serene and spacious, one could admire the interior of his mind as from
within a crystal and one could discover his infinite wisdom, his imperturbable peace.
Oh how I felt my mind, my heart brighten up.
Even more before Jesus my very passions are knocked down and do not dare to give me the
slightest bother.
I don't know if I'm wrong but I believe that one cannot see this Jesus so beautiful if
one is not in the most profound can.
That's in a very important statement because the problem that we all have is that we're
distracted by everyday life, we have all the stuff on the internet and your phones and
all your gadgets and everything else to distract you absolutely and you have whatever is going
on in the family and around you and all the rest of it and you're so distracted that if
the Lord stood in front of you you haven't enough attention to recognize him.
So she's saying this profound can.
Now that's the peace that passes all understanding, that's Philippians 4.7, Philippians 4.7.
So much so that the slightest breath of disturbance prevents one from receiving a sight so beautiful.
Now in the first four volumes Jesus tells Louisa continuously that there must not be
the slightest disturbance inside of you.
So let me explain that to you and that is we who give spiritual direction to others.
If a person comes and they explain a problem too you give an answer that they're not expecting.
The answer is a question and that is is your problem on the outside or on the inside?
They look at you and say what do you mean?
I have a problem.
I say no, no, no.
You can have a storm out there in Selbridge but it's not in my house.
The storm is kept out by all the walls of this house.
So has the storm entered into your inner being and you are stormy or is the storm outside?
That is the discernment that they need.
And if they manage to say the storm is outside so you're not having a problem just offer
it to the Lord, you're just having a cross and just offer it with the sufferings of Jesus
and offer it to the Lord.
But if you're having a storm on the inside you're having a real crisis because there's
no room for God but there's plenty of room for Satan to attack.
Because if you're disturbed Satan moves in you have no idea.
It's a bit like if somebody threw a stone at that window and created, you know the havoc
that a stone can create on a window.
The air gets in, the rain gets in, now Satan does that to the soul.
If there's the remotest crack he attacks.
That's why this profound peace and stillness is what allows the Lord to rain and keeps
all that evil out.
Ah yes, just seeing the serenity of his adorable forehead, the infusion of peace that one receives
in the interior is so great, I notice everything's infused and I believe that there's no disaster
or war most fierce which do not appease themselves before Jesus.
Oh my all and beautiful Jesus, if you communicate so much peace in the few moments you manifest
yourself in this life in such a way that one can suffer the most painful martyrdoms
the most humiliating pains but with the most perfect tranquility.
Now that is what Louisa was called to, she's a victim soul, now that's the specific grace
of victim souls.
She says what will it be like in paradise?
Or how beautiful is his most pure eyes sparkling with light?
It's not like the light of the sun that if one wants to look at it it harms our sight.
No, in Jesus' while being light one can very well fix his gaze on it and by just looking
at the interior of his pupil of a dark sky blue, or how many things it would tell me.
Now beside that you need to put the Song of Songs 512, that's the bride describing the
bridegroom, Song of Songs 512.
The beauty of his eyes is such that one of his gazes is enough to make me go outside
of myself and run after him through paths and through mountains and through the earth
and through the heavens.
One single glance is enough to transform me into him, that's all Song of Songs.
And make me feel a certain something divine descend upon me.
Now the next section is Song of Songs chapter 5 verses 10 to 16, Song of Songs chapter 5
verses 10 to 16.
Who can tell then the beauty of his adorable face?
His white complexion looks like snow colored with a shade of roses and the most beautiful
ones.
In his rosy cheeks one discovers the greatness of his person with the most majestic look fully
divine which strikes fear and reverence and at the same time infuses such confidence that
as for myself I have never found anyone who would give me the least shadow of confidence
that my dear Jesus gives.
Neither my parents, confessors nor my sisters, you can see that her extensive connections
are not very great, it's just her parents and her sisters and her immediate family.
Ah yes, that holy face while being so majestic is also so lovable and that loveliness attracts
one so much that the soul does not have the slightest doubt of being welcomed by Jesus
as ugly and sinful as she may see herself.
Beautiful also is his nose which descends to a very fine point proportioned to his most
sacred face.
This is small, his mouth small but extremely beautiful and his finest lips of a scarlet
color.
Now if somebody was artistic they could actually paint this.
While he speaks he contains so much graciousness that it is impossible to describe it.
As sweet as the voice of my Jesus it is gentle and it's harmonious.
While he speaks there is such fragrance coming out of his mouth that it seems that there
is nothing like it on the earth, it is so penetrating as to penetrate everywhere.
Now people who have the privilege of having saints around them and I know some people
in this country have the privilege of having saints around them, each of the saints has
a particular perfume and when you have a number of saints around you you get a mixture of
perfumes and this is what is being described here that the full conglomeration of all the
perfumes of sanctity is in Jesus, the whole out of them, the entire mixture, they are
all there.
So that represents all the virtues and all the attributes of God.
So I want to put Hebrews 4, 12 to 14 beside that.
Oh how many affections it produces, affections is responses from us, but who can say everything?
Then it is so pleasant that I believe no other pleasures can be found as many as the ones
that you will find in one single word of Jesus, Isaiah 55, 10 to 11.
Yeah, one single word of his, the word that goes forth and creates.
Now throughout all of the 36 volumes Jesus will describe his word as creative, in other
words when he speaks it happens and it is exactly what Genesis says that God said let
there be light and there was light.
God said this and it happened, God said and it happened.
You go to the Gospels, Jesus said go and wash in the pool of Siloam and the man said I went
and I washed and I saw, does it create a word?
And the Lord speaks to us in the depths of our being and if he says to you for example
forgive, he not only gives you a command, he gives you the creative power to do it.
It's much, much bigger, like if one of us said forgive, we're simply saying the word
and reminding you of something you ought to be doing.
With him it's completely different.
He actually creates in you the ability to do it.
It's a totally different thing altogether.
I know somebody who was completely transformed and I mean completely 100% transformed because
the Lord told him to forgive and he forgave and he forgave something massive.
But once he was told to forgive, he had the ability to do something that before that was
completely and totally impossible and the result of it was an extraordinary transformation.
So that's the one single word of Jesus.
The voice of my Jesus is immensely powerful, it is operative, that means it's effective
and at every moment he speaks he already operates that which he says, that's what I've just
told you.
Now the creative word, you'll find that in Genesis chapter one, you'll find it in John
chapter one but throughout the gospel as well.
Ah yes, beautiful is his mouth but it displays more of its beautiful grace in the act of
speaking while one can see those teeth so clear and so well arranged.
Now Louise is doing exactly what the bride and the song of songs does which is describe
the bridegroom and what she's doing is she's contemplating him.
And she will do exactly the same thing when he's on the cross and she will tell you exactly
what he's like on the cross and therefore she'll do all the reparations she has seen
his beauty beforehand and the destruction of that beauty in the crucifixion.
And his breath of love comes out, now his breath of love is the Holy Spirit coming from
him but you'll read about it in John 2022 that Jesus breathed it upon the apostles and
therefore they actually became a living church as a result of it.
And so this breath of love comes out igniting, darting through and consuming the heart.
Beautiful are his hands soft, white, most delicate with those fingers so perfectly crafted and
he moves them with such mastery as to be an enchantment.
Oh how beautiful you are, all beautiful, oh my sweet Jesus.
What I have said of your beauty is nothing, rather it seems to me that I've said a lot
of nonsense but what can I do, forgive me, it is obedience that wants it.
By myself I would not have dared to say one word knowing my insufficiency, she's done
pretty well hasn't she?
So when she when she uses the expression I think I've said a lot of nonsense she means
I'm not sure that I have communicated.
So the next section then is about the breath of God and I want to give you the Hebrew words
Ruach Adonai or UACH, the Jewish people never pronounce the sacred name and so instead of
pronouncing the sacred name they use the Lord and the Lord in Hebrew is Adonai.
Nowadays modern Jewish people call God Hashem means the and Shem means name, the name above
all names which Saint Paul talks about.
So now while I was seeing Jesus in the appearance already described he sent a breath from his
mouth which invested all of my soul.
It seemed that through that breath Jesus was drawing me towards himself and I began to
feel my soul going out of my body that's in and out of the body experience.
I really felt it go out from all parts from my head from my hands and even from my feet.
Now this will be the only time she'll tell you that in future she'll just simply say
I went out I went out of myself.
Since it was the first time that this was happening to me within myself I began to say
now I die the Lord has come to take me because usually the only time that your soul leaves
your body is when you're going to die but an out of the body experience can be induced.
In the past they people used what they called the straight jacket for prisoners that they
really wanted to punish and it was such a frighteningly suffocating experience that
many of them their souls went out of their bodies just to survive and so it can be induced
by ferocious pressure people in the new age movement use a terrible pressure of fasting
and all kinds of stuff to produce an out of the body experience and so they they claim
that they have astral projections and all this kind of stuff I don't know if you've
studied that but they are not going to a place where the Lord is wherever they're going that's
the amazing thing whereas when Louisa has an out of the body experience she's going immediately
into the presence of the Lord and her entire experience is an experience with the Lord.
In other words she's not having an out of the body experience for the sake of it whereas
the new age people think that they are really advanced spiritually if they have a new if
they have an out of the body experience.
I actually passed by a group of new ageers having a meeting in a Catholic monastery if
you wouldn't mind won't say where and they had all levitated off the floor so they all
thought that they were very spiritual and I knew that if I laughed loud enough that it
all fell because there it was not it was not what God was doing to them it was something
that they were inducing the body to do but they were the whole lot of them were approximately
a foot off the floor so I crapped past and I said the poor souls but I knew if I laughed
aloud they'd fall because it would break the power but then they'd probably kill me
so I wanted to live.
So since this was happening for the first time then she described it yeah she thought she
was going to die.
When I saw myself out of the body the soul had the same feeling as that of the body this
is a bit of revelation for you it's actually very good because people who have had near
death experiences will tell you they had all their feelings.
We have spiritual senses as well as physical senses and when we're in the body we're so
aware of the physical senses that we're not really aware of the spiritual senses that we
have but when people go deeply into prayer and into contemplation you become aware of
the spiritual senses and that's why Louisa says I was feeling the same.
With this difference that the body contains flesh nerves and bones where the soul doesn't
it is a body of light very interesting why would you use that expression because the
soul goes back to God who is light and the soul can only be full of love to go back to
God who is love so the only two things you can take with you to have in our light and
love can't take anything else.
So I felt a fear within me but Jesus continued to send me his breath and told me if being
deprived of me gives you so much pain now come together with me and I want to console
you and Jesus began his flight.
Now he's introducing her to something very important and that is that she's going to
be in bed in which you would die of boredom and tedium if nothing else for 64 years but
he's going to take her almost on a daily basis out and he's going to take her all over
the world he's going to take her out into the stars he's going to take her among the
planets he's going to take her to heaven he's going to take her to percutary and you need
to know that if we don't have the balance we couldn't cope.
So if she's to be stuck in that bed she also must see and hear and experience and she must
get out of the bed am I making sense to you.
If you have sorrow the Lord makes sure that there's some joy there to balance it out when
saint rays of lisue was dying she had an experience of the passion of Jesus spiritually but in
the middle of it the Lord gave her two weeks off to get her breath back is the way I would
put it but the doctors were completely confused that for two weeks none of the symptoms were
there and of course they started saying she's making it up and she died soon afterwards
but he gave her that little break and we need that you know that Patrick Pio's community
used to tease him and say he was the only one who knew how to get around the vow of obedience
because he was seen all over the world in by location you see and everybody else would
need permission and they'd need an airline ticket and what else and Patrick Pio's answer
was but I leave my body with you it's the body that causes the airline ticket so and
so Jesus began his flight and I began mine that this is out in the spirit world after
him and we went round throughout the whole vault of the heavens now the vault of the heavens
is what we call the sky and the sun moon and stars above it oh how beautiful it was to
stroll together with Jesus now put beside that Genesis 3 8 because the last time we heard
of God strolling with anybody it was in Genesis 3 8 that God walked with Adam in the cool
of the day as Genesis 3 8 and I would lean my head upon his shoulder and now notice my
head and my arm and all the rest of because you see the soul has exactly the same shape
as your body I have had a friend wonderful lady in England it is long since gone to the
Lord but when she had her first near death experience and her soul left her body in the
middle of the night and then the Lord told her you know it wasn't her time and she had
to go back and she said she really when she looked at the size of the body she said no
no I won't fit in there because you see once you go into the spirit world you expand everything
in you expands and she said I watched in total horror as my body as as I she said had to shrink
to fit into that thing into every single part of the body because once we go into that incredible
freedom on this the spirit side the body seems awfully small and confined and everything so
I would lean my head upon his shoulder and one arm around his shoulders and the other
hand in his hand now look the two of them are walking like lovers aren't they yeah she
has her head on his shoulder with one arm around his shoulders now that's intimate and
off isn't it and he was holding her hand and then Jesus would lean on me and we when we
reached certain places which were more inundated with iniquity so how my good Jesus suffered
she said in these places of iniquity I could see more clearly the sufferings of his adorable
heart that Sam 36 verse 9 in your light we see light Sam 36 verse 9 now when she's in
this out of the body experience she sees everything from God's perspective that's what makes
the saints and the prophets different to us because if we're looking at something from
our perspective it's limited let me illustrate it for you one year I gave her a treat in London
just before Christmas it's a definition of madness and I decided before I came home that
I would go down to Oxford Street and at least visit the darn place well that's total madness
before Christmas the crowds were so great that the police were shunting us in and out
of shops whether you wanted to go in or not the only safe place was walked beside the bus
which weren't allowed to go out there and I remember looking at this vast crowd when
I got out of one of the shops I wasn't interested in what they were asking us to do and I said
Lord how many cows would you have to kill to give any of these people a bit of meat for
lunch and the question was overwhelming how much bread would you have to make just to
give them one slice or to give them a bond and every question I asked was just overwhelming
because it was just a vast sea of humanity but the following day when I was flying over
London to come home to Ireland I looked down at 13.6 million people and I said God bless
London no problem different perspective you see the first time you're standing in the
middle of the problem and all you can see is the problem that's why I'm illustrating
it the other way you're seeing it from God's point of view and it's not a problem at all
that's that's the we only explained this in volume one because after that then presumed
you understand what's going on in the in the out of the body experiences but the Lord takes
Louisa out then she will see everything from God's point of view and therefore she will
be able to give us new perspective on things because you can only give what you have so
Jesus said to her my beloved helped me now you know that her whole story begins with him
asking her for help but I cannot take any more now that's that's the terrible sin that's
going on on the earth and while saying this he would draw his lips close to mine and he
would pour such bitterness that I would feel mortal pains in feeling that liqueur now remember
the last day I told you he gave her milk that gave her life and strength well the liqueur
is sufferings obviously she's calling it that because it must look like it because we use
language that we have so it was so very bitter it would enter into me and I would feel it
as if many knives pricks arrows were piercing me through now these knives pricks and arrows
that she's talking about are specific sins that are attacking in some and atrocious torment
would form in all of my body my limbs and as the soul would go back into the body it would
make the body participate in these sufferings so initially she was experiencing them totally
spiritually and then she goes back and the body experiences as well who can tell the
pains she said Jesus himself was the witness of it because the others could not imagine
mitigate my pains since I would be in that state of loss of consciousness now she will
she refuses point blank to use the word ecstasy and she just simply says loss of consciousness
which means I'm not available to you but I'm available to God which is what ecstasy is
and they would wait for the presence of the confessor for then they would also mitigate
at the call of obedience so Jesus alone could help me when he could see that my nature could
not take any more and reach the very extremes when there was nothing left for me but to breathe
my last oh how many times death made fun of me but the day will come when I will make fun
of her now unfortunately she's doing quite a long time and she's going to be towing and
froing on this subject she had such a desire for heaven it's totally amazing so Jesus would
come he would take me in his arms and draw me close to his heart wanted to put John 13 37
there where John the beloved put his head on Jesus's heart oh how I feel life coming back
into me and then he would pour a most sweet liquor from his lips and in this way the pains
would mitigate now notice one of the liquors is bitter and the other one is sweet other
times he would take me around together with him if there were sins of blasphemy against
charity and others he would pour those awful bitters into me if then there were sins of
dishonesty he would pour something of a stinking rottenness and I would return into myself and
I would feel that stink as well and the stench would be such that it would revolt my stomach
and I would feel faint now what she's getting is a graphic lesson as to the horror of these
sins and the problem is we're living in such a sinful world that we pay no attention to
dishonesty and this and that and the other and sometimes after taking food she said I
would bring it up and I would feel that rot come out of my mouth fixed mixed with the
blood in other words the rot that was given to her is real if it comes out of her mouth
mixed with the food that she's vomited up then it was real in other words it's not just
spiritual and this is one of the things that you have to sort of come to grips with with
Louisa that the presence of Jesus in her is real it's not just grace and the sufferings
she has are very real as well so in the next paragraph she's going to talk about the sins
of good people now if you remember the story of the Prodigal Son in Luke 15 that you're
right Luke 15 there the so-called good one was the elder brother do you remember and
the elder brother was finally opened his mouth and then you realized he wasn't a good one
because out of his mouth came bitterness and unforgiveness and resentment and all the
rest of it and these are all horrible sins unfortunately they're the sins of good people
and just because they're not robbing banks and they're not abusing others and they're
not killing others they think they're grand I've even heard people say but I've never
robbed a bank I said well go and do it then and get it off your chest in other words they're
using that as their definition of being a saint do you know what I mean I said if you're going
to be a saint sin has got to be on another planet so make sure you write down elder brother
there because this is elder brother syndrome it's called sometimes then he would bring me
into churches and even there my good Jesus was offended oh how awfully those works reached
his heart holy works yes but done roughly oh dear those prayers empty of interior spirit
that piety which is false and only seemingly right on the outside which seem to give more
insult than honored Jesus ah yes that holy pure upright heart could not receive those
works done so badly oh how many times he lamented oh let me okay before we go on beside that
put Habakkuk H A B B Habakkuk 113 your eyes are too holy to look upon evil that's for all
of this awful stuff that's done in church that people think is religious but with empty
of interior spirit it's nothing now the false piety only apparent empty of interior spirit
I want you to put beside that Matthew 15 verses 1 to 10 where Jesus literally attacks describes
and Pharisees on that very subject and he says these people honor me with lip service
but their hearts are far from me so in receiving the various sacraments instead of coming out
purified they come out dirtier in other words they commit sins actually in the reception
of the sacraments ah yes how much pain it was for Jesus to see people receiving communion
sacrilegiously oh dear pre celebrating the holy sacrifice of the mass in mortal sin
out of habit and some it is a horror to say even out of self interest I don't know I don't
know how a priest says mass out of self interest I haven't got that one at all I just don't
understand that oh how many I can understand that the mark is in or the sacrilegious thing
oh how many times my Jesus made me see these scenes so sorrowful how many times while the
priest was celebrating the sacrosanct mystery Jesus is forced to go into his hands because
he is called by the priestly authority that's their consecration one would see those hands
dripping with rotten blood or smeared with mud that's a priest living in a moral life
and we have the problem today of priests and bishops actually practicing homosexuality
this is a perfect description it's really really incredibly sad oh how pitiful then
was the state of Jesus so holy so pure in those hands which were horrifying at the mere sight
it seemed he wanted to escape from between those hands but he was forced to stay until
the species of bread and wine would be consumed how long is that fifteen minutes exactly so
if you in case you'll forget write it down it's exactly fifteen minutes so in the next
section then she's going to talk about bad priests sometimes while remaining there with
the priest Jesus would come hurriedly to me all lamenting and before I would I could
say it he himself would say to me daughter let me pour it into you I can take no more
have pity on my state which is too sorrowful have patients let us suffer together and while
saying this he would pour from his mouth into mine but who can tell what he poured it seemed
to be a bitter poison a fetid rot mixed with food so hard disgusting and nauseating and
sometimes it wouldn't go down who can tell then the suffering of this pouring of Jesus
produced if he himself had not sustained me I certainly would have died yet he would pour
in me but the smallest bit what would be the part for Jesus who contained tons and tons
of it she said oh how awful sin is now the victim soul and the saint both need to come
to a point of understanding the horror of sin because not only will they repudiate it
in their own lives but they will make reparation for others and in the divine will making reparation
and substituting for others is a very big part of our ministry because otherwise they won't
be saved if somebody doesn't make reparation for them and substitute for them so what is
Jesus doing here he's pouring the sins of the church into Louisa now we need an awful
lot of people today making reparation for the sins of the church otherwise a terrifying
chastisement will come our Lord let everyone know it so that all may flee from this monster
so horrible the monster is sin but while I would see these scenes so sorrowful other times
he would also make me seen seen so consoling and beautiful as to be in rapturing now to
see he needs to compensate her it can't all be horrible human nature can't take that
she needs the balance and this was to see good and holy priests celebrating the sacrosanct
mysteries or God how high great and sublime is there a ministry how beautiful it was to
see the priest celebrating mass and Jesus transformed into him it seemed that was not the priest
but Jesus himself that celebrated the holy sacrifice and sometimes he would make the
priest disappear completely and Jesus alone would celebrate the mass and I would listen
to him now I have known people who have actually seen that that instead of seeing the priest
they actually saw Jesus celebrating the mass and I'm talking about people in Ireland now
I'm not talking about people in far from places oh how touching it was to see Jesus recite
those prayers do all those ceremonies and movements that the priest does who can tell
how consoling it was for me to attend not to see these masses together with Jesus how
many graces I received how much light and how many things I understood comprehend is
a word that use quite frequently understanding is a word that we use but since these are
past things I don't remember them so clearly so I kept silent so you'll notice that in
all of this she's getting very deep understanding as to the nature of sin very deep understanding
as to the nature of the mass and the sacraments in other words Jesus is evangelizing her and
giving her the true doctrine so that she can actually base her life on that and when we
come into a deep relationship with the Lord volumes one to four are actually necessary
to make sure that anything missing in the foundations of our evangelization can be filled
in as well so the next paragraph is an interlude where Jesus reacts to Louisa wanting to be
silent you see Louisa has this temptation that she doesn't really want to explain things
because she thinks you won't understand and it's going to be a battle between Jesus and
Louisa and also the priests and Louisa to get her eventually to say everything now she will
fight that one tooth and nail but gradually you'll have to get up to about volume twenty
before you'll get full messages from her that is I mean you can get a four a four page
as one message in other words she's saying everything but at the beginning she doesn't
want to do it she says I know you wouldn't understand or it'll be too long or whatever
and she makes all these excuses and then Jesus begins to say to her that it is extremely
important that she writes now you have to understand that in volume one she does not
know that this material is going out of her room the only person she thinks will ever read
it is the priest she doesn't understand why she's being told to write every single detail
if she had realized that we'd be studying this a century later she would have died so
it becomes a crisis deeper and deeper for her when she begins to realize this is actually
something the Lord is going to publish but as I am saying this Jesus has moved in my
interior ideas called me he doesn't want me to do that in other words keep silent and
not explain things our Lord how much patience it takes with you she says that's a fantastic
expression isn't it we say that of each other but I mean who would dare to say that about
the Lord well then I will continue oh sweet love I will say a few little things would
give me your grace to be able to manifest them because by myself I would not dare to
utter one word about mystery so sublime and so profound so Jesus wants her to say more
about the mass which are going to get in the next paragraph now while seeing Jesus are
the priest celebrating the divine sacrifice Jesus would make me understand that in the
mass there is all the depth of our most holy religion sacrosanct means most holy ah yes
the mass tells us everything and it speaks to us about everything the mass reminds us
of our redemption it speaks to us step by step about the pains that Jesus suffered for us
it also manifests to us his immense love for he was not content with dying on the cross
but he wanted to continue his state of victim in the most holy Eucharist the mass also tells
us that our bodies decayed reduced to ashes by death will rise again on the day of judgment
together with Jesus you'll get that in John chapter 6 and you want to eat my flesh and
drinks my blood has life and so on so it will rise again on the day of judgment together
with Christ to immortal and glorious life now this is described very well in one Corinthians
15 and it's approximately the first 10 verses approximately Jesus made me understand that
the most consoling thing for a Christian and the highest and most sublime mysteries of
our holy religion are Jesus in the sacrament now when Jesus Jesus in the sacrament you mean
the holy Eucharist you would get the impression from here that there was only one sacrament
instead of seven so right down there the holy Eucharist because she's she's a stony sacrament
she's actually speaking about so the most sublime mysteries of our holy religion are
Jesus in the most holy Eucharist and the resurrection of our bodies to glory it's not amazing
I wouldn't have expected her to say those two I would have expected well I would expect
her to include them but to put in a few other things as well these are profound mysteries
she says which we will understand only beyond the stars a lovely expression isn't it but
Jesus in the most holy Eucharist makes us almost touch them with our own hands in other words
that you get to the point where you can actually touch this mystery at a deeper level but then
you have got to be very quiet after communion and one of the terrible mistakes that's made
today is that people sing even inappropriate stuff by that I mean that they're not singing
about communion distracting you and then within five minutes you're up and you're out talking
and that sacred presence is physically there for fifteen minutes that's why you know when
this kind of stuff started in churches I made a decision and I've kept it ever since that
I leave the church instantly so that I'm not talking to anybody so that I can make my
have my silence on the way home to do my thanksgiving because people are taking it from you without
realizing what they're doing and they're taking an incredible treasure from you I see
the problem is if you stay sitting in the bench somebody will come over and talk to you that's
why I leave and so I always look like someone in a desperate hurry to leave the church but
I am because I want to make the most of this fifteen minutes I mean that sacred presence
is only there fifteen minutes so why on earth would you not benefit from it as a lovely country
man said to me one day I've got all to myself imagine I said you got it as the most wonderful
expression he actually got it I've got all to myself and he said I suddenly realized I
ask other people to pray and I have him for myself that wonderful that man started doing
all night vittles when he realized he had got all to himself these are profound mysteries
and the Lord wants us to really enter into them first his resurrection second his state
of annihilation under that species though it is certain that Jesus is there present alive
and real so beside that I want you to put Philippians 2 verses 6 to 11 in other words
his state was divine he humbles himself becomes one of us crucified and risen it's certain
that he is there then once those species are consumed his real presence no longer exists
in other words after the fifteen minutes that's why it's the most important fifteen minutes
of your life and as the species are consecrated again he comes again to assume his sacramental
state so Jesus in this in the most holy Eucharist reminds us of the resurrection of our bodies
to glory just as Jesus when his sacramental state ceases resides in the womb of God in
other words goes back to his origin in God his father and it's the same for us when our
lives cease our souls go and make their dwelling in heaven in the womb of God while our bodies
are consumed so one can say that they no longer exist but then with the tragedy of the omnipotence
of God our bodies will acquire a new life and uniting with the soul will go together to
enjoy the eternal beatitude can there be anything more consoling for a human heart than the
fact that not only the soul but also the body will be beatified with eternal contentment
and this where the worldly people today are completely deceived they want all their contentment
now and then they left nothing on the other side which is really sad it seems to me that
on that day that's the day of resurrection it will happen as when the sky is starry and
the sun comes out what happens when it's immense with its immense light the sun absorbs the
stars and makes them disappeared but the stars are there it's just you don't see them it's
just that the light is so great I want beside that I want you to put the book of Daniel
a chapter 12 verse 3 and that is that the saints shine like stars in God's heaven I read
a description up in volume 14 was it that Jesus said that some people who barely do the absolute
minimum to be saved he said they're the ones that would be like Stardust floating around
the place but there won't be stars and there won't be planets and they won't be these
great constellations because they only barely made it to the other sides very interesting
that he uses this expression all the time so even though the immense light of the sun
is there the stars do actually exist and it's only when the sun decides to go to bed that
you see the stars again and in all of these writings the sun represents God because God
is light and when you realize that in these writings the sun represents God I have to
bring you back to a little reflection and that is if you go back to the time of the pharaohs
the people were worshiping the sun as God and the thing is they were only partially wrong
because the sun is the source of light is the source of heat is the source of joy is
the source of all the fecundity on the earth and blah blah blah is the source of health
and all the rest of it they just didn't know there was a person behind it and the way I
describe that is that it's a wonderful moment for a mother and her child when the infant
sucking the breast looks up and realized there's a person behind the food and the little finger
goes up to touch am I right or am I right and it's a great moment for the mother as well
because the mother is being acknowledged as the origin of that life now the pharaohs only
needed to make one step to go beyond worshipping the actual sun itself to go to worship the
person behind it a God who is light and the sadness is that God sent Moses to tell them
and they couldn't take it it's sad but it's even worse then at the time of Christ when
the light of the world Jesus himself came and the children of Israel wouldn't accept him
and it's even worse again that today after 2000 years of Christianity the western world which
was evangelized first has just rejected the light of the world so the sun is God and all the blessed
souls are the stars that's what Daniel says that we shine like stars with his immense light and God
will absorb all of us into himself in such a way that we all exist in God now in one of the higher
volumes Louisa says that she was taken up to heaven she was taken up to heaven a number of times
and she went looking for our blessed lady and couldn't find her and she said that she had to go
very very far into the most blessed Trinity to find her because she was so high it's not fantastic
and I'm giving it to here to let you hear what's being said here that we're absorbed into that light
but when she was able to penetrate very deeply into the most blessed Trinity she could then see
our blessed lady in a very special place all by ourselves so God will absorb us all within himself
in such a way that we will exist in God and will swim in the immense sea of God or how many things
Jesus in the most holy Eucharist tells us but who can tell them all it would be really too long
that this is Louisa in volume one not wanting to say everything you see if the Lord allows it
I will reserve saying something else on other occasions in other words she's going to stop now
no matter who says so during these exits that the Lord would make me do that is the out of the body
experiences sometimes he would renew the promise of the marriage which I had already mentioned
who can tell the ardent yearnings that the Lord infused in me for that mystical marriage
to take place many times I would solicit him telling him most sweet spouse hurry no longer
delay my intimate union with you please let us bind each other with stronger bonds of love
now the thing is you won't become a saint unless you want it I can tell you that for absolute
certain you don't become a saint by mistake just as I will never become a pilot taking an aeroplane
off the ground unless I decide to be a pilot and I decide to go for the training and I decide to
pass the exams that makes sense in the same way I will not become a saint unless I decide I want
to go there I'm telling you that because many good people don't make a clear decision that I want
what the Lord wants for me they just sort of go along but they don't make a clear decision
that I actually want it and if you tell the Lord very clearly that you want he will train you for
that but if he's not hearing anything from you he's saying well they don't really want it so why
should I waste the training would you waste training on someone who you know didn't really want to be
a pilot but it wouldn't mind sort of learning a couple of things about it would you waste the
money at the time no you would not unless you're a person who didn't know what to do with their
money so in the same way here you have Louise saying to the Lord I want this mystical marriage
now you're going to have a disaster for life if two persons male and female if we stay with reality
do not both want the marriage if only one of them wants the marriage and the other one is sort of
saying well okay yeah I'll go along with it like you're not going to have a decent marriage are you
but if both of them really want it then you're going to have something dynamic and something great
am I talking English yeah well it's the same spiritually as well so she's telling him to hurry
up oh please let us bind each other with the stronger bonds of love so that no one may ever
again be able to separate us even for a simple instance so when you get up to the volumes over
volume 20 you will hear Jesus calling louise my inseparable louise so it happened she actually
got there and the only other person he calls my inseparable is his mother and Jesus would correct
me about one thing and then about another we would say teach me rather than just correct me I remember
that one day he said everything that is on the earth everything everything you must remove not only
from your heart but also from your body that's Deuteronomy six four to ten you shall love the
Lord your God with all your heart soul mind and being now because louise is being called to a very
exalted relationship with Jesus more is demanded of her than will be demanded of you and me because
we're not called to exactly the same thing that she was called to us so a separation from the world
and from material things for her had to be absolutely drastic you cannot understand how harmful are
the slightest earthly shadows and how much they hinder love that these shadows are our attachments
now living in the ordinary world as all of us are you probably don't even know you have any
but it can be illustrated much more easily if you talk about a situation that I actually was
involved with giving a retreat to a contemplative nuns and one of them had been given a very special
pen for her silver jubilee now these women have a solemn vow of poverty and so from the day she
took her vows she owned nothing and all of a sudden she was allowed to keep this pen and so she was
telling me about this pen I could see that she absolutely loved it and all the rest of it and I
decided I had to be the baddie you know and I said is that pen going to get you into purgatory
your poverty was going to get you straight up don't let something as obnoxious as a pen
make you experience fire and you know they were all looking at me as if I was you know
baddie number one do you know what I mean I said the greatest temptation is that you cling to
something that is nothing now let me tell you John of the Cross said that John of the Cross said
if a bird is tied to a tree and cannot fly
it's a slave isn't it it's tragic but is it more tragic if it is tied by a rope or a thread
if a bird is tied to a tree by a thread that's your pen
or something little it's much more tragic to be enslaved to something small than something great
and the problem with good people who want to be a saint and want to get close to the Lord
is that it's the tiny things that they can cling to
it's the small things I give you that just as a piece of wisdom it might save you a few years
of struggle because you say to yourself no I'm not letting that put me into purgatory no way
and the pen is only an example it could be anything it could be absolutely anything
and the amazing thing is it very often is something small
that this is mine nobody's having this one so just to be very careful about it
and that's what Jesus is saying to her that the earthly shadows that's the little bits of things
that you cling on to sometimes it's not a pen it's not outside of yourself it can be your own opinion
I had a friend who was always a hundred percent right so what was I a hundred percent wrong
could you have a discussion no you could only have a dictation so I used to allow the gentlemen
to do as much talking as he could and I'd eat my dinner
and then one day he said you haven't spoken I said no what's the point in speaking if he's a hundred
percent right so we can we can actually have things we cling on to on the inside
sometimes you cling on to an opinion you have about another person
or very dangerous because people change all the time as they move either forwards or backwards
or whatever and so if we hold a particular opinion about a person it can be that we are holding them
in judgment so just be careful that the thing you cling on to can be outside of you like the pen
or it could be inside of you either so jesus says they're very harmful and they hinder love
now hinder love meaning going to that union with god immediately louisa said if i have something else
that must be removed tell me if i'm ready to do it now she was extraordinarily generous with the
law but as i was saying this i myself watch this i realized i had a gold ring on my finger
portraying the image of the crucifix now isn't that holy and immediately i said to him holy
spouse do you want to take it off you want me to take it off and he said since i myself will give
you a more precious more beautiful ring which will be my living image have my living image
impressed on it and every time you will look at it in your heart not on your finger you will receive
new arrows of love that one isn't necessary now if the lord is talking to you like this there's always
a reason why he's doing it and only dawned on louisa oops why i'm a ring so because this is my last
session that i'm doing with you i'm going to go on for the next little while because we're going to do
the spiritual marriage in the next paragraph the long before day finally arrived after not a little
suffering i remember that it was almost one year that i had been continuously in bed
it was the day of the purity of mary most holy that's February the second isn't it
on the night before that day my lover jesus made himself seen all festive he drew near me took my
heart in his hands because that's what marriage is about is about the heart isn't it and he looked
at it over and over again he dosted it i love that and then he gave it back to me and then he took a
garment of immense beauty whose background seemed to be a surface of gold streaked with various
colors you remember joseph and his multicolored garment and he clothed it me with that garment
then he took two gems as if they were earrings and he bejeweled my ears so he's obviously not
against earrings some of you might like that then he adorned my neck and my arms so he's not against
the necklace either and surrounded my forehead with the crown of immense value all enriched with
precious stones and gems all reflect with light now everything that comes from him of course is light
because he is light and it seems to me that those lights were as many voices which resounded among
themselves speaking in clear notes of the beauty power fortitude and all the other virtues of my
holy spouse jesus who can tell what i understood and in what sea of consolation my soul was swimming
in what is impossible to say it now put beside that one Corinthians two nine things that the eye
has seen and the ear has heard and the heart has what the Lord has prepared for those who love him
but we're not able to say it because the problem is when you're in the out of the body experience
you have the spiritual language you come back into the body and that spiritual language doesn't
communicate you have to somehow say it in our worldly language and then the person who has experienced
that exalted thing finds that this worldly language doesn't express it you know it's like Sister Faustina
saying she didn't like the painting she said that's not like him and yet it was the description she
actually gave so it was it was accurate but of course it wasn't what she really saw he couldn't
communicate that divine presence and that divine beauty now while he was crowning my forehead jesus
said to me most sweet spouse i placed this crown upon you so that nothing may be missing in order
to make you worthy of being my spouse but then after our wedding is finished i will take you
with me to heaven to keep it for you at the moment of death in other words the crown was going to be
her crown of glory finally he took a veil and covered me completely with it from head to foot
and then he left me that way it seemed to me that there was a great meaning in that veil because the
demons in seeing me all covered in that veil were so frightened and had such fear with me that they
fled terrified they whatever it was they got the message the very angels were around me with such
veneration that i myself was confused and full of blushing so there you have the lord having put
this extraordinary protection around her and that the demons couldn't touch her at all
one morning on the same day jesus made himself seen again all affable sweet and majestic and
together with his most holy mother and saint kathrin now we want to find out which kathrin it is because
there's a whole lot of kathrin's i think it's cnf yeah first the angels sang him while saint kathrin
assisted me and blessed mother took my hand and jesus put the ring on my finger then we embraced and
he kissed me and so did blessed mother then we had a conversation all of love jesus told me of the
great love that he had for me and i also told him of the love i had for him the most holy virgin
made me understand the great grace that i had received and that the correspondence that would
be required of me and so on now i'm going to to stop here but just tell you that put a heading
over the next paragraph and you can start there with with a melda and that is my new married life
because it's one thing to have a wedding it's another matter then you have to move into a completely
new way of life and we'll leave it there for the moment.